okay [ __ ] we're gonna do guardian
angel with Bierce son let's do this hey
I think I'm ready to make a bunny what
do you have in mind my time I think it's
a safe bet it'll be worth it okay
[ __ ]
[ __ ] flying their hair
it's the fast car
I like this you know psycho likes this
kind of travel isn't a fast guy hey this
Ascot oh oh [ __ ] on the tip of my dick
Jesus yeah we have [ __ ] on terrific it's
like the weirdest feeling it's like when
you like it like like it's just like you
know what it feels like it feels like
when you are like almost having it you
make it a pit of jelly sandwich PB&J
sandwich you know and you don't have
that much peanut butter left you know
and you're using a knife and you're like
scraping in there but you get someone
your knuckles cuz your hand just looks
so into the jar and that's what it feels
like you know three honest okay and God
did the Saints headquarters go into the
penthouse
okay that's really cool well that's
gayest like this check it out boss
what's up since this used to be a
syndicate crib but I poke around and see
what they left behind all right so what
am I looking at safety deposit keys
don't you want to know what it is they
all got locked up a syndicate will know
we have the keys they'll be waiting for
us to make a move I guess then you
better watch my back okay all right
let's go
what the [ __ ] is this do you have a plan
I'm gonna go in open the safety deposit
boxes get the [ __ ] you really think the
morning so I won't object just be ready
when I come out I'll be ready all right
okay I admit it okay I'm coming out now
keep my cover until I can find for it I
watch you did we get some good [ __ ] oh
yeah that [ __ ] I just did so much damage
to my own guy that sucked up
Wow okay earlier my job with this [ __ ]
it's Hawking about fish
yes Jesus
okay a lot of screaming that's okay that
everyone's entitled to their opinions
okay it's an anime now
trying to protect my haole but he's like
not gonna die but that car is [ __ ] up
that's all I gotta say
help me out
another roadblock
a building and just over the bridge I'll
sit up and be waiting I can't then make
it up you [ __ ] die that's because of
my [ __ ] guns did we get some good
[ __ ] oh yeah okay good
[ __ ] there's like fire on the ship okay
okay I got a lot better the last time
I'm drop it up dad I'm drop it up
okay okay
a lot of fire I get it I've been there
shet I am chop it up it's getting [ __ ]
up
so many [ __ ] that's just broken up
here help me out [ __ ] I got you bro
I got you bro
another roadblock
my building is just over the bridge I'll
sit up and be waiting
okay look in Allegan oh [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] is he going
this skirt sucks okay all right just
[ __ ] huh hey where else
okay
[ __ ] 380 lat
still think I'm just a pretty face
there's gonna be some guys in that
[ __ ] alley
I did it okay yeah it's out for Harambee